et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
brice hortefeux bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés
européens anciens ministres des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par stefan glarner
ans jean stéphane bonjour organe qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france
on commence en parlant de sécurité de
terrorisme brice hortefeux et cette
proposition de guillon calquer c'était
dimanche au grand jury l'a défendu le
rétablissement de la cour de sûreté pour
les français fichiers pour terrorisme et
radicalisation il dit pas de liberté
pour les ennemis de la liberté je
souhaite une justice d'exception pour
ces cas particuliers
concrètement par la d'incarcération
préventive sans possibilité d'appel est
ce que vous partagez cette mesure et ses
propos nommé il ya deux choses il ya le
fond c'est le combat que l'on doit mener
contre le terrorisme pourquoi doit-on
mener ce combat parce que le danger on
le sait c'est un danger qui est
permanent qui est réel qui nécessite une
vigilance et de nombreux moyens et de
nouveaux moyens et pourquoi se serrer
elle parce que depuis 2012 il ya eu 1 37
attentats terroristes on peut même
considérer qu'un a sans doute eu plutôt
45 m'enfin 37 qui sont qui sont recensés
que cela fait dans notre pays 270
victimes que
des attentats sont déjoués 17 depuis
2017 et que la france est aujourd'hui
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir et on va
revenir sur ces questions c'est que la
france et le à la fois un pays source
est un pays cible donc c'est ça la
situation particulière donc eu que les
responsables publics se concentre sur ce
sujet c'est normal c'est l'un vers ce
qui serait surprenant maintenant sur la
proposition qui a été faite par
guillaume pelletier et sur la forme je
pense que c'est très utile que dans les
familles politiques chacun réfléchisse
apporter sa pierre sa contribution pour
améliorer les conditions de vie de notre
société c'est utile simplement il faut
pas que ça parte systématiquement dans
tous les sens et que ce soit un concours
lépine de propositions qui sont parfois
je ne dis pas ça d'ailleurs pour celle
de guillaume pelletier vais parfois qui
sont des propositions très loufoque ou
qui vont finalement aboutir à l' inverse
de ce que l'on souhaitait donc il y à
une proposition majeure de guillaume
pelletier qui est celle de supprimer un
certain nombre de cas la possibilité
d'appel moi je ne partage pas cet avis
je pense que la possibilité d'appel et
c'est non pas une faiblesse mais une
protection
donc si ce n'est pas une faiblesse et si
c'est une protection je pense qu'il faut
pas y toucher mais si je sur le
rétablissement de la cour de sûreté
je suis plutôt hostile à des
juridictions spécifique mais il peut y
avoir des exceptions mais sur le
principe je me pose la question de
principe je suis plutôt réservé or vous
n'êtes pas le seul à être réservés en
fait dès dimanche christian jacob le
président des républicains a recadré
assez sèchement guillaume police il faut
rappeler que c'est quand même le numéro
deux du parti et qui est là en
l'occurrence s'est exprimé sur sa propre
initiative et dont sur des sur des
choses qui sont pas du tout dans la
ligne des républicains en fait c'est un
plan b là aussi mais bien sûr que
je comprends que vous souhaitiez
encourager une forme de polémique et
vous dire conseille pas aux penseurs du
parti au niveau des centres émergentes
et ensuite tu vas bien passé et je pense
qu'on était vu comme tout julie je
partageais pas changer d'avis même
l'expérience de la vie publique le monde
d'abord il ya les aspirations
individuelles des élus à se faire
remarquer ici
évidemment si j'ai un gros l'anonymat
s'ils sont dans l'anonymat ce
responsable n'avait pas tout à fait à
leur espérance morts vous savez moi il y
avait un ancien sénateur un ancien
ministre
je le dis ici à public sénat qui était
michel charasse qui expliquait que les
médias ronde est fou alors c'est je dis
pas ça pour celui dont on parle
maintenant mais j c'est vrai que il ya
des saisies l'idée qu'il faut à tout
prix sortir une originalité
donc ça fonctionne c'est pas forcément
ce je crois très utile en revanche ce
qui est utile c'est que chacun engagé un
effort de réflexion etc ce qui est aussi
utile c'est qu'ils réfléchissent au
temps de la formulation là aujourd'hui
nous sommes engagés dans la préparation
de scrutins locaux territoriaux il faut
qu'on soit rassemblés il faut qu'on
fasse bloc il faut que chacun joue sa
partition
mais en ayant comme l'a dit christian
jacob ce levier référence au prix junte
et républicains en jouant collectif
bon ben je collective du collectif aux
politiques c'est une ambition mais c'est
pas toujours une réalité c'est juste une
question de temps brice hortefeux c'est
un problème que le vice président des
républicains et des positions
divergentes du président des
républicains visiblement d'une grande
majorité de la partie mais je prends une
fois je suis pas d'accord avec ce que ce
que dit guillaume pelletier sur une
grande partie sur 80% il ya aucun souci
et mais je pense que c'est bien que l'on
nourrissent des débats mais il faut
peut-être je pense que il ya un temps
pour tout et donc c'est une erreur
d'avoir joué une partition en solo alors
que nous sommes engagés dans un combat
collectif
et justement au moment où vous êtes
engagés dans un combat pour les
élections est ce qu'il peut encore
rester vice-président du parti
guillaume pelletier dans ces conditions
avant la course je suis bien j'ai bien
nous sommes un pays qui a coupé la tête
de marie antoinette m'enfin et
aujourd'hui on nous avons à une
direction qui a été choisi par christian
jacob c'est là lui de déterminer ce
qu'il convient de faire moi je suis pour
le rassemblement pas pour la division et
pas pour les exprimer justement est-ce
que c'est pas une illustration
supplémentaire qu'il y à deux lignes un
jour j'ai honoré qu'un parce qu'il n'y a
pas que ça qui l'a dit guillaume
pelletier là aussi des dépositions sur
le front républicain
il a dit dimanche que c'était une info
sur politique grotesque le front
républicain il a dit quelques jours
avant que pas une voix ne devait aller à
emmanuel macron qu'il avait qui l'assuré
porter les mêmes convictions que robert
ménard robert ménard c'est le maire de
béziers qui est proche du rassemblement
national
est-ce qu'il peut continuer à porter
cette voie au sein des républicains et
est-ce que vous approuvez ses propos sur
le front est logique je une famille
politique ça surement enfin et des
heures sur le rôle d'une famille
politique savait y avait un livre qui
s'appelait en 1905 s'appeler les partis
politiques de roberto michaël guigou
henri t on s'aperçoit que les choses ont
très peu changé depuis 1905
est ce que c'est bien ce que c'est mal
c'est une question mais en tout cas ça a
très peu changé
et en plus ce que je crois c'est que la
vocation la vocation d'une formation
politique c'est pas de soustraire ces
d'additionner ces salons le son rôle est
donc je pense qu'il faut additionner les
compétences il faut additionner les
personnalités et non pas chercher à
diviser à soustraire mais sur le
vieillissement lyon pelletier guillaume
pelletier puisque vous donc il doit être
content parce que là donc pas beaucoup
de lui donc jamais ce jeudi mais son
fils younes a dit aussi des républicains
sur le fond de vous vous êtes d'accord
est ce que le front républicain c'est
une imposture jeu
je vous dise qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
faut éviter c'est tombé dans le piège
qui est ailleurs le piège était grossier
c'est pas et ne s'est pas une petite
fille zeiss est une grosse corde
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'ambition du président de la république
est l'ambition de la présidence du
rassemblement national c'est de réduire
notre pays un face-à-face savez c'est un
grand classique qui a rien de très
original à l'époque bolis moi je suis de
2,2 de sensibilité gaulliste de c'était
lille objectif c'était qui a rien entre
les gaullistes et les communistes
d'ailleurs c'était discours de malraux
entre les gueules communiste rennes où
il n'y a rien bon et bien là et
l'objectif d' emmanuel macron c'est
qu'il y ait simplement face à face le
rassemblement national pensant que c'est
comme ça qu'il est là sur son succès je
pense que c'est assez cynique mais assez
peu moral et surtout inutile pour la
démocratie
donc nous on n'est pas obligé de rentrer
dans ce jeu là nous nous avons à aux
républicains une vocation c'est de
rassembler des personnes de sensibilité
de droite et du centre de les rassembler
qu'on soit d'accord à 80% sur des
objectifs communs et puis que chacun est
ensuite ses spécificités ça c'est sûr
que entre guillaume pelletier je sais
pas d'amis ahmad le président du groupe
à l'assemblée
il ya des nuances que ça nous empêche de
travailler ensemble entre les
républicains et le rassemblement
national oui mais fait tout de suite
c'est un dpe l'éternel
une éternelle discussion avons-nous les
mêmes positions qui emmanuel macron non
nous n'avons pas les mêmes positions qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas les mêmes
positions emmanuel macron sur les
questions sociétales on n'a pas les
mêmes positions game et makro sur la
question migratoire on n'a pas les mêmes
positions qui emmanuel bach rond sur le
communautarisme on n'a pas l'âme et
position des manuels macron sur la
fiscalité
ouais je pourrait décliner sa est ce que
nous avons et des différences avec le
front national moi j'y vais je suis
député européen je vois les députés
européens du rassemblement national
on n'a pas les mêmes d'abord ne pas les
mêmes racines le fonds national puise
son engagement dans l'antigaullisme moi
je puise mes racines dans le goal is
fetjaine grosse différence et pour se
limiter à ce sujet on n'a pas les mêmes
approches de l'europe au fond d'eux les
leurs à les élus du rassemblement
national sont contre la construction de
l'europe bmo au nouveau républicains
nous considérons que compte tenu de
l'évolution du monde et bien on a
intérêt à être ensemble pour parler
d'une voix à l'échelon européen plus
tout d'être seuls isolés en tout cas ce
sont en tout cas deux familles
politiques dans lequel je me reconnais
pas ou deux courants de pensée dans
lequel je ne me reconnais pas ça veut
dire qu'il ya le chantre emmanuel macron
marine le pen il ne vaudrait c'est
précisément jeu pour commencer je peux
recommencer ce que je dis aujourd'hui
mais voilà c'est moi je ne veux pas de 6
en politique on en crève de trop de si
là nous nous battons pour arriver en
tête et c'est notre seul objectif de
démontrer aux français que les
républicains peuvent être utiles parce
que la seule question qui compte parce
que ça c'est la vraie question c'est
est-ce que nous sommes utiles ou est-ce
que nous ne sommes pas si nous arrivons
à démontrer à nos concitoyens que nous
sommes utiles et bien nous survivrons et
si nous n'y arrivons pas eh bien nous
disparaîtrons c'était une des règles de
la démocratie
donc la mécanique est la vôtre c'est
tout faire pour être au second tour que
ce soit aux régionales à la
présidentielle propose une alternative
c'est bien ça ou je vais même un peu
plus pour être tout à fait clair
l'objectif c'est sûr cela étant le
deuxième tome est en plus de gagner vous
aviez oublié cette étape mais c'est
celle là aussi je dis juste sans
reprendre les propos de guillaume
pelletier
qui parle la position politique
grotesque comme l'a dit orianne est ce
que la notion front républicain n'a pas
vécu notamment auprès des électeurs est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui marche
encore en 2000 en 2000 en 2021 ou pour
2022 ou est-ce que les gens ne résonne
plus comme ça à votre avis moi je pense
que bien sûr le du temps a passé depuis
les années 80 si c'est une musique qui
me chez les électeurs en fait en disant
de toute façon vont veut plus le terme
même de front républicain passe moins
bien la notion de foi font république et
un porte en elle un germe qui est très
dangereux c'est celui d'accord
d'appareil
donc c'est pas le bon thème moi je crois
qu'il faut que l'on avance avec ses
idées je viens de très schématiquement
régine angée différence en défense et
masquant et nous le rassemblement
national et nous nous je pense que notre
rôle notre vocation c'est d'assumer un
rôle central
c'est cela notre rôle bon donc
évidemment ça n'arrange pas ni emmanuel
macron ni le rassemblement national
on va parler puisqu'on a commencé en
parlant de terroristes du fond cette
fois de là
de la lutte contre le terrorisme ya une
nouvelle loi antiterroriste qui va être
débattue aujourd'hui par les députés
présenté par le gouvernement elle vise à
renforcer la prévention des actes de
terrorisme à renforcer leurs
enseignements mais aussi à renforcer le
suivi des condamnés terroristes à leur
sortie de prison
est ce que pour vous c'est la bonne
réponse et le gouvernement le dit lui
même il ya une ligne de crête par
rapport à la constitution est ce qu'il
faut changer la constitution pour vous
face à la menace terroriste actuelle bon
d'abord il faut guillaume pelletier
d'ailleurs la 10è lire il faut toucher à
la constitution du mas tremblante selon
l'expression est connu et moi je suis
pour j'ai été ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai donc eu la responsabilité de la
lutte contre la délinquance de la lutte
contre le terrorisme j'ai vécu moi une
période qui était plutôt protégé puisque
quand la paire belge exercer ses
fonctions il n'y a pas eu de drame aussi
violents que ceux que l'on vient de deux
heures de rappeler il y à la menace
quand la menace augmente quand la menace
se développe il faut naturellement que
l'arsenal législatif se développe lui
aussi il faut pas qu systématiquement on
soit en retard
je vous donne un exemple très simple
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
le gouvernement a annoncé c'est une là
dessus il a raison et il a annoncé une
aura un renforcement des moyens des
écoutes téléphoniques c'est très
important
mais aujourd'hui la réalité de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
ça passe surtout par le suivi d'internet
on s'aperçoit que les terroristes selon
tout ce qui a été
mais étudier utilisent de moins en moins
de téléphones sont de plus en plus
prudents sur dans ce domaine mais qui
sont obligés de passer par internet donc
il faut renforcer ses moyens deuxième
élément je peux me naturellement me
tromper il y aura certainement des
contre exemples mais je ne crois pas et
je roulais dit d'ailleurs ici
il ya quelque temps je ne crois pas
qu'en matière terroriste au loup
solitaire ça je n'y crois pas je ne
crois pas au type qui te complètement
cinglé tout seul comme ça dans il ya de
moins en moins d'attentats téléguidé on
pense qu'il n'y en a d'ailleurs que 4%
ils sont des attentats téléguidé de
l'extérieur mais en revanche il y as
lorsqu'il ya un passage à l'acte il ya
un environnement qui peut être un
environnement familial un environnement
amical un environnement sportif les
salles de sport un environnement
éducatif
il ya toujours quelque chose dans ce
rapport pas donc ça nécessite
effectivement un suivi maintenant vous
connaissez les chiffres vous avez 8200
en gros inscrit aux fichiers de
prévention de la radicalisation et vous
avez dans les fichiers s j'en avais un
peu autour de dix mille et qui sont là
aussi
fish est pour radicalisation est ce
qu'on peut suivre vingt mille personnes
en permanence la réponse est non mais ce
texte est à mon texte et tout ce qui s
est s q est-ce suffisant ce n'est jamais
suffisant est-ce que ça s'adapte à la
réalité de la menace oui encore une fois
je vous rappelle nous avons repose ma
question est ce qu'il faut changer la
constitution pour sa nacelle à cécile à
ma nation je vous réponds si la menace
évolue
oui il faut pousser bousculer l'arsenal
législatif mais encore une fois pourquoi
tout ça parce que ça ça peut paraître
des petites mais je t'ai dit pourquoi
tout ça c'est parce que la menace al est
permanente
la france concentre la réelle le tiers
des débats elle seule des attentats qui
sont commis dans l'union européenne ces
32 % en france et ses 16 % derrière pour
l'allemagne et 8 % pour l'espagne et les
pays bas
ben voilà ces chiffres là montrent qu'
on est un pays qui est un pays cible il
ya une réalité que vous et vos si au
début la conversation vous avez cité le
nombre d'attentats depuis 2012 mais il
ya aussi un certain nombre de
djihadistes ou de terroristes qui ont
été condamnés y compris à des longues
peines qui aujourd'hui les ont purgé et
sont en passe de sortir on n'est pas sûr
que sont moins dangereux qu'au moment
ils sont rentrés en prison qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour contre ça
bertrand proposé par exemple créer des
peines de sûreté très longue
est-ce que ça c'est envisageable ce
serait une bonne solution par un oui il
faut qu'il entende âgées bertrand la
peine de sûreté par dont 50 ans pour lui
la vie bertrand méheut sûr toujours le
nom d'année la question est actuellement
peu peut-être examiné qu'il y ait des
mesures qui soient des mesures
spécifiques de suie oui parce que vous
connaissez la réalité vous avez en gros
depuis 2000 12450 français qui sont
partis sur la zone irako syrienne
vous en avez à peu près 300 qui sont
revenus déjà tôt qui sont judiciariser
meilleurs qu'on sépare les autres un
connais pas les autres
et puis vous avez en prison en réalité
autour de 600 détenus pour radier pour
de terrorisme acte de terrorisme menace
terroriste est un site 8 et 7 un peu
plus de 700 702 je crois aujourd'hui le
chiffre exact qui sont détenus de droit
qui sont des débuts de droit commun mais
qui sont soupçonnés de radicalisation
bon ça fait quand même un petit monde ça
fait 1500 personnes fermant il voulait
sortir les et qui naturellement ceux de
j'allais dire la génération de 2000 des
condamnés de 2013 2014 et que peu
comment sortir et on sait qu'il ya eu
sur ces deux dernières années plus d'une
centaine qui sont sortis donc oui qu'il
faut il faut qu'il y ait un suivi qui
soient touchés et bien sûr qui à
léquilibre liberté et protection et mais
là aujourd'hui la protection parfois
c'est de toucher un peu aux libertés
mais juste du coup la peine de sûreté de
50 ans par les condamnés pour faire
jouer je vais dire le nombre d'années on
peut discuter
qu'il y ait des mesures accrues de suivi
en revanche oui
un dernier mot puisque guillaume
pelletier encore lui il lui lille veut
carrément sortir provisoirement de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
est ce que vous le député européen vous
dit que c'est une bonne solution
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
à l'évidence à
basculer dans un réflexe qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité des menaces qui pèsent sur notre
société
alors qu'il faut sans doute le dire et
il faut le rappeler aux responsables de
cette cour est ce qu'il faut en sortir
pour autant attention aux coups de pied
dans la fourmilière on va parler
justement de l'union européenne à
stéphane et du plan de relance cinquième
plan de relance européen qui va devenir
concret c'est aujourd'hui que démarre le
processus historique démission de de
dettes
est ce que cette crise aura permis de
faire avancer l'union européenne sur le
plan budgétaire
bon déjà on avait un peu espérer que ça
fasse progresser sur le plan sanitaire
bond etf or force est de reconnaître que
dans un premier temps ce qui était
apparu comme une bonne il ya eu trois
temps en réalité premier temps sa part
et c'est une bonne idée on unit nos
forces
c'était ça la bonne idée qu'est ce que
ça voulait dire ça veut dire vous
souvenez pour les vaccins où on les
achète tous ensemble comme ça donc aussi
les tard il en avait gosset quantité
c'était en gros il y avait deux
objectifs les tarifs et la quantité
les tarifs oui il ya sans doute une
négociation utile et sur la quantité
la vérité c'est que ça n'a pas montré
ses résultats mais pourquoi il y avait
l'idée de quantité ces deux japon pour
éviter que des grands pays comme la
france comme l'allemagne en bénéficient
et que les plus petits de co2 en clair
des petits pays d'europe centrale
essentiellement voire de zone
méditerranéenne n'ont bénéficié ce qui a
du sens sur vos succès de départ était
la bonne l'application a été mauvaise
dans un premier temps aujourd'hui il ya
une correction
moi je suis en heureux qu'enfin l'union
européenne réagisse par exemple en
engageant des procédures contre
astrazeneca qui n'a respecté aucun de
ses engagements quantitatif donc là
l'européenne
l'europe a réagi et d'ailleurs on le
doit en grande partie au commissaire
français thierry breton qui est était
plus présent sinon dans les usines que 2
n'était pas leur propre président
d'astrazeneca qui lui était venu en
australie bon donc sur ce plan là ça a
été positive sur le plan budgétaire
c'est une bonne chose mais en même temps
cela rappelle la lourdeur des mécanismes
vont citer que ce soit mais qu'on
observait le plan le plan était décidé à
l'été dernier c'est tenir entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui et pourquoi anti le
voyons aujourd'hui je rappelle c'est
parce que il faut naturellement un vote
du parlement il faut aussi le vote et 27
parlements nationaux quand j'ai mon sort
on comprend pourquoi c'est lourd mais il
n'en reste pas moins ça a été décidé et
alors après ça rend tout simplement
l'application c'est une europe s'il
manque encore d'agilité c'est une place
mais bon deuxième élément est ce que
pour la france et bien oui la france est
bien avoir votre quarantaine de
milliards c'est possible positif c'est
pascal italie l'italie c'est 206
milliards donc il ya une grande
différence
mais chez c'est utile mais donc là
aujourd'hui l'europe démontre
concrètement effectivement qu'elle peut
apporter un mot sur strasbourg puisque
les eurodéputés saillé vont re siéger à
strasbourg au mois de juin c'est la
première fois depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire depuis un an et demi est
ce que le siège de strasbourg
elle a été affaiblie par cette crise
sanitaire voir clairement menacé
clermont strasbourg est menacée
strasbourg est protégé par les traités
mais abandonner les textes
lancre finit par sécher un bon mais
strasbourg est menacé parce que les
députés européens n'ont pas siégé à
strasbourg depuis mars 2020 et ils vont
sans doute siéger nous allons sans
d'autres siéger la semaine prochaine et
je sais que il ya des pétitions de
parlementaire et qui demande à ce que
cette fois ci on ne retombe plus à
strasbourg
donc il ya clairement une menace sur le
siège de l'union européenne je trouve ça
d'ailleurs à titre personnel je trouve
ça très très malsain parce que tous ces
pays qui nous ont rejoint et nous ont
rejoints et c'était dans les wagons il
n'était pas dans la locomotive
donc il savait que la locomotive nous
conduisait à strasbourg donc je pense
que ça serait un mauvais signal que l'on
touche à strasbourg qui est qui a été
choisi comme symbole de la construction
peine et de la réconciliation franco
allemande
une dernière question de ses fans sur un
exode vers son xavier bertrand qui est
le mieux placé aujourd'hui à droite même
s'il est plus cher républicain pour la
présidentielle est ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut il peut s'imposer notamment à
al à l'issue des régionales le mieux
classé c'est à dire parce que vous êtes
en est certain que d'autres
vous avez observé qu'il y avait d'autres
candidats qui s'étaient déclarés par le
score laurent wauquiez en écoute à cette
étape de ma vie publique moi je suis
très décontracté je vous dis tout de
suite ça non je fais pas de calcul à 12
bande pour savoir qu'ils ont joué les
choses c'est très simple il y a un
candidat désiré qui est nicolas sarkozy
il ya un candidat naturel qui est
françois barois et puis il ya des
candidats légitimes pour ma famille
politique sont bruno retailleau que son
cas une grande cohérence que sont michel
barnier qui a une grande expérience il y
à valérie pécresse qui ajoute une
sensibilité féministe écologiste
et puis il ya bien sûr laurent wauquiez
il ya dont le retrait deux ans de la vie
publique lui permettra j'en suis
convaincu un rebond
donc nous avons plusieurs candidats et
nous choisirons sur cette liste mais
xavier bertand vous m'interrogez comment
des républicains xavier bertrand a
quitté l'est républicain donc aller les
premiers vous finissiez en réveil
pécresse étaient présentes devant les
jeunes républicains là j'ai plus été
forum for marly s'est adressé en fin
mais non c'est ce n'est pas tout à fait
le jeu mais nous choisirons il nous nous
rassemblerons d'où les choix qu'on le
connaisse qu'il faut le faire
moi je suis d'un prénom je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit à la rentrée qui est
des signaux après les régionales et que
ça se concrétise à la rentrée joué on a
là on est sans doute la première force
militante on est à l'évidence la
première force territoriale nous sommes
la première force au sénat sommes la
majorité au sénat
nous sommes la première force à
l'assemblée régionale on va je l'espère
il est gagné les régionales
bon on a aujourd'hui un problème
d'incarnation si vous voulez c'est très
simple je pense profonde une expression
un peu triviale et je terminerai d'autre
part là sans doute c'est que nous avons
un couloir de nage ne sait pas encore
qui met le maillot bas il faudra que
pour le désigne pour vous c'est
passionnant spontanément s'est passé pas
celui auquel je pense je pense mais s'il
faut se rassembler mais on se rassemble
c'est enfin nous devrons nous rassembler
et je ferai partie de ce rassemblement
autour de celui qui sera le meilleur
merci beaucoup merci hortefeux
[Musique]